The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN GUTTAG: Hi, everybody.
Welcome back to class.
I have a lot to cover
today, so I'm just
going to get right to it.
So you may remember at
the end of last lecture,
I talked about
the Empirical Rule
and said that there were
a couple of assumptions
underlying it.
That one is the mean
estimation error is zero.
And second, that the
distribution of errors
will be normally distributed.
I didn't probably
mention at the time,
but we often call this
distribution Gaussian
after the astronomer Carl Gauss.
And it looks like that.
Normal distributions are very
easy to generate in Python.
I have a little example
here of generating, not
a real normal distribution,
but a discrete approximation
of one.
And the thing to really
notice about it here
is this line random.gauss.
So that's a built in function
of the random library.
The first argument is the mean.
And the second argument
is the standard deviation
or a mu and sigma as
they're usually called.
Every time I call that,
I will get a different--
or usually a
different random value
drawn from a Gaussian with
the mean, in this case of 0
and a standard deviation of 100.
I'm then going to
produce a plot of those
so you can see
what it looks like.
And I'm going to do that
using some things we
haven't seen before.
So first of all,
we've seen histograms.
So pylab.hist
produces a histogram.
Bins tells us how many bins
we want in the histogram.
I said we want 100.
The default is 10.
Dist is the values
it will use for it.
And then this is something we
haven't seen before, weights.
Weights is a keyword argument.
So normally when we
produce a histogram,
we take all of the values,
the minimum to the maximum,
and in this case, we would
divide them into 100 bins,
because I said, bins equals 100.
So the first bin
might be, well, let's
say we only had values
ranging from 0 to 100.
The first bin would be all
the 0's, all the 1's up to all
the 99's.
And it weights each
value in the bin by 1.
So if the bin had 10
values falling in it,
the y-axis would be a 10.
If the bin had 50
values falling in it,
the y-axis would go up to 50.
You can tell it
how much you want
to weight each bin, the
elements in the bins.
And say, no, I don't want
them each to count as 1,
I want them to count
as a half or a quarter,
and that will change the y-axis.
So that's what I've done here.
What I've said is
I've created a list
and I want to say for
each of the bins--
in this case I'm going to weigh
each of them the same way--
the weight is going to be 1
over the number of samples.
I'm multiplying it by
the len of dist, that
will be how many items I have.
And that will tell me how much
each one is being weighted.
So for example, if I
have, say, 1,000 items,
I could give 1,000
values and say,
I want this item
weighted by 1, and I
want this item over here
weighted by 12 or a half.
We rarely do that.
Usually, what we want is to
give each item the same weight.
So why would I want it not
to be weighted at just one?
Because I want my y-axis to
be more easily interpreted,
and essentially give me
the fraction of the values
that fell in that bin.
And that's what I'm doing here.
The other new thing
I'm doing here
is the plotting
commands, including
pylab.hist, many of
them return values.
Usually, I just ignore
that value when we just
say pylab.plot or pylab.hist.
Here I am taking the value.
The value in this
case for a histogram
is a tuple of length 2.
The first element is
a list or an array,
giving me how many
items are in each bin.
And the second is
the patches used
to produce the beautiful
pictures we're use to seeing.
So here what I'm going
to do is take this value
so that I can do
this at the end.
Now, why would I want
to look at the fraction
within approximately
200 of the mean?
What is that going to
correspond to in this case?
Well, if I divide
200 by 2 I get 100.
Which happens to be
the standard deviation.
So in this case, what I'm
going to be looking at
is what fraction
of the values fall
within two standard
deviations of the mean?
Kind of a check on the
empirical rule, right?
All right, when I run
the code I get this.
So it is a discrete
approximation
to the probability
density function.
You'll notice, unlike
the previous picture
I showed you which was nice
and smooth, this is jaggedy.
You would expect it to be.
And again, you can see it's
very nice that the peak is what
we said the mean should be, 0.
And then it falls off.
And indeed, slightly
more than 95%
fall within two standard
deviations of the mean.
I'm not even surprised that
it's a little bit more than 95%
because, remember the magic
number is 1.96, not 2.
But since this is
only a finite sample,
I only want it to be around 95.
I'm not going to worry too much
whether it's bigger or smaller.
All right?
So random.gauss does a nice job
of giving us Gaussian values.
We plotted them and now
you can see that I've
got the relative frequency.
That's why I see fractions in
the y-axis rather than counts.
And that would be because of the
way I use the weights command.
All right, let's return to PDFs.
So as we said last
time, distributions
can be defined by Probability
Density Functions,
and that gives us
the probability
of some random variable
lying between two values.
It defines a curve where
the values in the x-axis
lie between the minimum and
maximum values of the variable.
And it's the area
under the curve--
and we'll come back to this--
between those two
points that give us
the probability of an example
falling in that range.
So now let's look at it
for a normal distribution.
You may recall from the last
lecture this rather exotic
looking formula which defines a
PDF for a normal distribution.
And here's some code
that's as straight forward
an implementation as one could
imagine of this formula, OK.
So that now is a
value that, given
a mu and a sigma and an x,
gives me the x associated
with that mu and sigma, OK?
And you'll notice there's
nothing random about this.
All right, it is
giving me the value.
Now, let's go down here.
And I'm going to,
for a set of x's, get
the set of y's corresponding
to that and then plot it.
I'm going to set
mu to 0 and sigma
to 1, the so-called standard
normal distribution.
And I'm going to look at the
distribution from minus 4 to 4.
Nothing magic about that
other than, as you'll see,
it's kind of a place where
it asymptotes near 0.
So while x is less
than 4, I'll get
the x-value, I'll get the
y-value corresponding to that x
by calling Gaussian,
increment x by 0.05
and do that until I'm done.
And then simply, I'll plot the
x-values against the y-values
and throw a title on
it using pylab.title.
All right, code make sense?
Well, this is where I got
that beautiful picture
we've looked at before.
When I plotted here, it
looks, actually quite smooth.
It's not, it's really connecting
a bunch of tiny little lines
but I made the points
close enough together
that it looks at least here
smooth at this resolution.
So we know what the
values on the x-axis are.
Those are the values
I happen to want
to look at, from minus 4 to 4.
What are the values
on the y-axis?
We kind of would like
to interpret them
as probabilities, right?
But we could be pretty
suspicious about that
and then if we take this
one point that's up here,
we say the probability of
that single point is 0.4.
Well, that doesn't make any
sense because, in fact, we
know the probability
of any particular point
is 0 in some sense, right?
So furthermore, if I chose
a different value for sigma,
I can actually get this to go
bigger than 1 on the y-axis.
So if you take sigma
to be say, 0.1--
I think the y-axis goes
up to something like 40.
So we know we don't have
probabilities in the range 40.
So if these aren't
probabilities, what are they?
What are the y values?
Well, not too surprising
since I claimed
this was a probability density
function, they're densities.
Well, what's a density?
This makes sense.
I'll say it and then
I'll try and explain it.
It's a derivative of the
cumulative distribution
function.
Now, why are we talking about
derivatives in the first place?
Well, remember what
we're trying to say.
If we want to ask, what's the
probability of a value falling
between here and here,
we claim that that
was going to be the area under
this curve, the integral.
Well, as you know
from 18.01, there's
a very clear relationship
between derivatives
and integrals.
And so if we interpret each of
these points as a derivative,
in some sense the
slope here, then we
can look at this
as the area just
by integrating under there.
So to interpret a PDF, we
always do it mathematically.
Actually, I do it
just by looking at it.
But the only really interesting
mathematical questions to ask
have to do with area.
Once we have the
area, we can, then,
talk about the probabilities
of some value falling
within a region of the curve.
So what's interesting
here is not
the numbers per se on the y-axis
but the shape of the curve,
because those numbers
have to be related
to the numbers on the
x-axis, dx, dy right?
We're looking at derivatives.
All right, so now, we have
to talk about integration.
I promise you'll only hear
about it for another few minutes
then we'll leave the topic.
So I mentioned before
SciPy as a library
that contains a lot of useful
mathematical functions.
One of them is integrate.quad.
Well, the integrate
part is obvious.
It means integration.
Quad is telling you
the algorithm it's
choosing to do the integration.
All of these integrals are going
to be actual approximations
to the real integral.
SciPy is not doing
some clever mathematics
to get an analytical solution.
It's using a numerical technique
to approximate the integral.
And the one here happens
to be called quadrature,
it doesn't matter.
All right, you can pass
it up to four arguments.
You must pass it to
function to be integrated,
that makes sense.
A number representing the lower
limit of the integration--
you need to give it that.
A number representing
the upper limit--
you need to give it that.
And then the fourth
argument is a tuple
supplying all values
for the arguments,
except the first of the
function you are integrating.
I'll show you an example
of that on the next slide.
And we'll see that it returns
a tuple, an approximation
to the result, what it
thinks the integral is,
and an estimate
of how much error
there might be in that one.
We'll ignore the
error for the moment.
All right, let's
look at the code.
So we start by importing
scipy.integrate.
That gives us all the
different integration methods.
I'm not going to show
you the code for Gaussian
since I showed it to you
a couple of minutes ago.
But I wanted you to
remember that it takes three
arguments, x, mu, and sigma.
Because when we get down
here to the integration,
we'll pass at the function
Gaussian and then the values
that we want to integrate over.
So those will be the values
that x can take upon.
And that will change
as we go from mu
minus the number of standard
deviations times sigma
to mu plus the number
of standard deviations
times sigma.
And then, this is the optional
fourth argument, the tuple, mu,
and sigma.
Why do I need to pass that in?
Because Gaussian is a ternary
argument, or a function
that takes three values.
And I'm going to
integrate over values
of x so I have to fix mu and
sigma to constants, which
is what I'm doing down here.
And then I'll take
the zeroth value,
which is its estimate
of the integral.
All right, so that's
the new thing.
The rest of the code is
all stuff you've seen.
For t and range
number of trials,
I'm going to choose a random
mu between minus 10 and 10
and a random sigma
between 1 and 10.
It doesn't matter what
those constants are.
And then for the number
of standard deviations
in 1, 1.96, and 3,
I'm going to integrate
Gaussian over that range.
And then we're just going
to see how many of them
fall within that range.
In some sense,
what we're doing is
we're checking the
empirical rule.
We're saying, take the Gaussian.
I don't care what
mu and sigma are.
It doesn't matter.
The empirical rule will
still hold, I think.
But we're just
checking it here, OK?
Well, here are the results.
So from mu equals 9
and sigma equals 6,
I happened to
choose those, we'll
see the fracture within 1,
fraction within 1.96 and 3.
And so for these
random mus and sigmas,
you can see that all
of them-- and you
can set them to whatever
you want when you
get your hand them the code.
Essentially, what we have is,
whoops, the empirical rule
actually works.
One of those beautiful cases
where you can test the theory
and see that the
theory really is sound.
So there we go.
So why am I making such a big
deal of normal distributions?
They have lots of nice
mathematical properties,
some of which we've
already talked about.
But all of that
would be irrelevant
if we didn't see them.
The good news is they're
all over the place.
I've just taken a few here.
Up here we'll see SAT scores.
I would never show that
to high school students,
or GREs to you guys.
But you can see that
they are amazingly
well-distributed along
a normal distribution.
On down here, this is plotting
percent change in oil prices.
And again, we see something very
close to a normal distribution.
And here is just looking at
heights of men and women.
And again, they clearly
look very normal.
So it's really quite impressive
how often they occur.
But not everything is normal.
So we saw that
the empirical rule
works for normal distributions.
I won't say I proved it for you.
I illustrated it for you
with a bunch of examples.
But are the outcomes of the
spins of a roulette wheel
normal?
No.
They're totally uniform, right?
Everything is equally probable--
a 4, a 6, an 11, a 13, double-0
if you're in Las Vegas.
They're all equally probable.
So if I plotted
those, I'd basically
just get a straight
line with everything
at 1 over however many
pockets there are.
So in that case, why does
the empirical rule work?
We saw that we were doing
some estimates about returns
and we used the empirical
rule, we checked it
and, by George, it was
telling us the truth.
And the reason is
because we're not
reasoning about a
single spin of the wheel
but about the mean
of a set of spins.
So if you think about it,
what we were reasoning about
was the return of betting.
If we look at one spin--
well, let's say we bet $1.
The return is either minus 1
because we've lost our dollar.
Or if we get lucky and our
pocket happens to come up,
it was 36, I think, or 35.
I forget which, OK?
But that's all.
So if we plotted a
histogram, we would
see a huge peak at minus
1 and a little bump
here at 36 and
nothing in the middle.
Clearly, not a
normal distribution.
But what we're
reasoning about is not
the return of a single spin
but the return of many spins.
If we played 1,000 spins,
what is our expected return?
As soon as we end up reasoning,
not about a single event
but about the mean of something,
we can imply something
called the Central
Limit Theorem.
And here it is.
It's actually for something
so important, very simple.
It says that given a
sufficiently large sample--
and I love terms like
sufficiently large
but we'll later put a
little meat on that--
the following three
things are true.
The means of the samples
in a set of samples,
the so-called sample means
will be approximately normally
distributed.
So that says if
I take a sample--
and remember, a sample will
have multiple examples.
So just to remind people.
A population is a
set of examples.
A sample is a subset
of the population.
So it too is a set of
examples, typically.
If this set is
sufficiently large--
certainly 1 is not
then it will be the case
that the mean of the means--
so I take the mean
of each sample
and then I can now
plot all of those means
and so take the mean
of those, right--
and they'll be
normally distributed.
Furthermore, this
distribution will
have a mean that is close to
the mean of the population.
The mean of the means
will be close to the mean
of the population.
And the variance
of the sample means
will be close to the variance
of the population divided
by the sample size.
This is really
amazing that this is
true and dramatically useful.
So to get some insight,
let's check it.
To do that, postulate that we
have this kind of miraculous
die.
So instead of a die that when
you roll it you get a number 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, or 6, this
particular die is continuous.
It gives you a real
number between 0 and 5,
or maybe it's
between 1 and 6, OK?
So it's a continuous die.
What we're going to do is
roll it a lot of times.
We're going to
say, how many die?
And then, how many
times are we going
to roll that number of die?
So the number of die
will be the sample size--
number of dice will
be the sample size.
And then we'll take a
bunch of samples which
I'm calling number of rolls.
And then we'll plot
it and I'm just
choosing some bins
and some colors
and some style and
various other things
just to show you how we
use the keyword arguments.
Actually, I said the number of
rolls is the number of trials.
But it isn't quite
that because I'm
going to get the
number of trials
by dividing the number of
rolls by the number of dice.
So if I have more dice, I get
to have fewer samples, more
dice per sample, all right?
Then we'll just do it.
So it will be between 0
and 5 because random.random
returns a number between 0 and
1 and I'm multiplying it by 5.
And then we'll look at the
means and we'll plot it all.
Again, we're playing
games with weights just
to make the plot a
little easier to read.
And here's what we get.
If we roll one die, the
mean is very close to 2.5.
Well, that's certainly
what you'd expect, right?
It's some random
number between 0 and 5.
2.5 is a pretty good guess
as to what it should average.
And it has a standard
deviation of 1.44.
And that's a little
harder to guess
that that's what it would be.
But you could figure it
out with a little math
or as I did here
with the simulation.
But now, if I roll 50
dice, well, again, the mean
is close to 2.5.
It's what you'd expect, right?
I roll 50 die, I get the
mean value of those 50.
But look how much smaller
the standard deviation is.
More importantly,
what we see here
is that if we look at the
value, the probability
is flat for all possible
values between 0 and 5
for a single die.
But if we look at the
distribution for the means,
it's not quite Gaussian
but it's pretty close.
Why is it not Gaussian?
Well, I didn't do it an
infinite number of times.
Did it quite a few, but
not an infinite number.
Enough that you didn't want
to sit here while it ran.
But you can see the
amazing thing here
that when I go from looking at
1 to looking at the mean of 50,
suddenly I have a
normal distribution.
And that means that
I can bring to bear
on the problem the
Central Limit Theorem.
We can try it for roulette.
Again I'm not going to make you
sit through a million trials
of 200 spins each.
I'll do it only
for fair roulette.
And again, this is a
very simple simulation,
and we'll see what we get.
And what we see is it's
not quite normal, again,
but it definitely
has that shape.
Now, it's going
to be a little bit
strange because I can't
lose more than one,
if I'm betting one.
So it will never be
quite normal because it's
going to be truncated
down on the left side,
whereas the tail can
be arbitrarily long.
So again, mathematically
it can't be normal
but it's close enough in
the main region, where
most of the values lie,
that we can get away
with applying the empirical
rule and looking at answers.
And indeed as we
saw, it does work.
So what's the moral here?
It doesn't matter what the
shape of the distribution
of the original
values happen to be.
If we're trying to estimate
the mean using samples that
are sufficiently
large, the CLT will
allow us to use the
empirical rule when
computing confidence intervals.
Even if we go back and look at
this anomaly over in the left,
what do you think would happen
if I, instead of had 200, have,
say, 1,000?
What's the probability of the
average return being minus 1
of 1,000 bets?
Much smaller than for 100 bets.
To lose 1,000 times in a
row is pretty unlikely.
So to get all the
way to the left
is going to be less
likely, and, therefore,
the thing will start
looking more and more normal
as the samples get bigger.
All right, and so
we can use the CLT
to justify using
the empirical rule
when we compute
confidence intervals.
All right, I want to look at
one more example in detail.
This is kind of an
interesting one.
You might think that
randomness is of no use for,
say, finding the value
of pi because there's
nothing random about that.
Similarly, you might think
that randomness was of no use
in integrating a
function, but in fact,
the way those numerical
algorithms work
is they use randomness.
What you're about to
see is that randomness,
and indeed things related
to Monte Carlo simulations,
can be enormously useful, even
when you're computing something
that is inherently not random
like the value of pi here.
And we won't ask you to
remember that many digits
on the quiz and the exam.
All right, so what's pi?
Well, people have known about
pi for thousands and thousands
of years.
And what people knew was
that there was some constant,
we'll call it pi.
It wasn't always called that.
Such that it was equal
to the circumference
of a circle divided
by the diameter,
and furthermore, the area
was going to be pi r squared.
People knew that way back to the
Babylonians and the Egyptians.
What they didn't know
is what that value was.
The earliest known estimate
of pi was by the Egyptians,
on something called the
Rhind Papyrus pictured here.
And they estimated pi
to be 4 times 8 over 9
squared, or 3.16.
Not so bad.
About 1,100 years
later an estimate of pi
appeared in the
Bible, Kings 7:23.
It didn't say pi is
but it described--
I think this was a construction
of King Solomon's Temple.
"He made a molten sea,
ten cubits from one brim
to the other."
it was round.
It was a circle.
"His height was five cubits
and a line of 30 cubits
did compass it round about."
Well, if you do the
arithmetic, what does
this imply the
value of pi to be?
3, and I'm sure that's what
Mike Pence thinks it is.
About 300 years
later, Archimedes
did a better job of it.
He estimated pi by constructing
a 96-sided polygon.
There's a picture of one.
It looks a lot like a circle.
On the left is one
with fewer sides.
And what he did is he then--
since it was a polygon he
knew how to compute its area
or it's circumference and
he just counted things up
and he said, well,
pi is somewhere
between 223/71 and 22/7.
And that turns out
to actually-- if you
take the average of that it
will be a really good estimate.
2000 years after Archimedes,
the French mathematicians
Buffon and Laplace
proposed finding
the value of pi using what we
would today call a Monte Carlo
simulation.
They did not have a
computer to execute this on.
So what they proposed--
it started with
this mathematics.
They took a circle
and inscribed it
in a square, a square of
two units of whatever it
is per side.
And therefore we know that
the area of the square
is 2 times 2 or 4.
We know that the area of
the circle is pi r squared.
And since we know that r is 1--
because that's the square
it's inscribed in--
we know that the area of
a circle is exactly pi.
What Buffon then proposed was
dropping a bunch of needles
at random-- kind of like when
Professor Grimson was sorting
things--
and seeing where they land.
Some would land in the
square but not in the circle.
Some would land in the circle.
You would ignore any that
landed outside the square.
And then they said, well, since
they're falling at random,
the ratio of the needles in the
circle to needles in the square
should exactly equal
the area of the square
over the area of
the circle, exactly,
if you did an infinite
number of needles.
Does that make sense?
Now, given that, you
can do some algebra
and solve for the
area of the circle
and say it has to be the
area of the square times
the number of needles
in the circle divided
by the needles in the square.
And since we know that
the area of the circle
is pi that tells
us that pi is going
to equal four times the
needles in the circle.
That's 4 is the area
of the square divided
by the number of
needles in the square.
And so the argument
was you can just
drop a bunch of these
needles, see where they land,
add them up and from that
you would magically now know
the actual value of pi.
Well, we tried a simulation
one year in class but rather
than using needles
we had an archer
and we blindfolded him so he
would shoot arrows at random
and we would see
where they ended up.
There's a video of this
here if you want to see it.
I'm going to play only the
very end of the video which
describes the results.
Maybe we should just use
Python to build a Monte Carlo
simulation instead.
So that's what happened.
After it was all
over, Anna came up
and gave me some sound advice.
Yeah, I was very proud of that
particular shot with the apple.
I had hoped the student would
put it on his or her head
but no one volunteered.
That was not done blindfolded.
Any rate, so here
is the simulation.
So first we have
throwing the needles.
For needles in range 1 to
number of needles plus 1,
we're going to choose
the random x or random y
and we're going to see whether
or not it's in the circle.
And there we will use
the Pythagorean theorem
to tell us that, all right?
And we'll just do
this, and then we're
going to return
exactly the formula we
saw in the previous slide.
Now, comes an interesting part.
We need to get an estimate.
So we start with the
number of needles
and the number of trials.
For t in range number
of trials, we'll
get a guess by throwing
number of needles.
And then we'll append that
guess to our list of estimates.
We'll then compute the
standard deviation,
get the current
estimate which will
be the sum of the
estimates divided
by the len of the estimate,
just the mean of the estimate.
And then we'll
print it, all right?
So given a number of needles
and a number of trials,
we'll estimate pi and we'll
give you the standard deviation
of that estimate.
However, to do that within
a certain precision,
I'm going to have
yet another loop.
And I'm showing you
this because we often
structure simulations this way.
So what I have
here is the number
of trials, which is not so
interesting, but the precision.
I'm saying, I would like
to know the value of pi
and I would like
to have good reason
to believe that the
value you give me
is within 0.005, in this
case, of the true value.
Or maybe more
precisely, I would like
to know with a confidence of
95% that the true value is
within a certain range.
So what this is going to do
is it's just going to-- and I
should probably use 1.96
instead of 2, but oh, well--
it's just going
to keep increasing
the number of needles,
doubling the number of needles
until it's confident
about the estimate,
confident enough, all right?
So this is a very common thing.
We don't know how many needles
we should need so let's
just start with
some small number
and we'll keep going
until we're good.
All right, what
happens when we run it?
Well, we start
with some estimates
that when we had 1,000 needles
it told us that pi was 3.148
and standard deviation
was 0.047 et cetera.
So a couple of things to notice.
One, are my estimates of pi
getting monotonically better?
You'd like to think,
as I add more needles,
my estimates are
getting more accurate.
So that's question one.
Are they getting more accurate?
Not monotonically, right?
If we look at it, where
are they getting worse?
Well, let's see.
All right, 3.148, well, 3.13
is already worse, right?
So I double the
number of needles
and I get a worse estimate.
Now, the trend is good.
By the time I get here, I've
got a pretty good estimate.
So overall as I look at
larger samples, a bigger
subset of the
population, my estimates
are trending towards
better but not every time.
On the other hand, let's look
at the standard deviations.
What we see here is that
the standard deviations
are, indeed, getting
monotonically better.
Now, there's nothing
mathematical guaranteeing that,
right?
Because there is
randomness here.
But I'm increasing the
number of needles by so much
that it kind of overrides
the bad luck of maybe getting
a bad random set.
And we see those
are getting better.
So the important
thing to see here
is not that I happened
to get a better estimate,
but that I know more
about the estimate.
I can have more
confidence in the estimate
because it's closing in on it.
So the moral here is it's
not sufficient to produce
a good answer.
I've said this before.
We need to have reason
to believe that it
is close to the right answer.
So in this case, I'm using
the standard deviation
and say, given that it's
gotten quite small--
you know, 1.96 times 0.002
is indeed a small number.
I could make it
smaller if I wanted.
I have good reason
to believe I'm
close to the right value of pi.
Everyone agree with that?
Is that right?
Not quite, actually.
It would be nice
if it were true.
But it isn't.
So let's look at some things.
Is it correct to state
that 95% of the time we
run this simulation you'll
get an estimate of pi
between these two values?
I don't expect you to do
the arithmetic in your head
but the answer is yes.
So that is something
we believe is
true by the math we've been
looking at for the last two
lectures.
Next statement, with
a probability of 0.95,
the actual value of pi is
between these two things.
Is that true?
In fact, if I were to say,
with a probability of 1,
the actual value is pi is
between those two values,
would it be true?
Yes.
So they are both true facts.
However, only the
first of these can be
inferred from our simulation.
While the second
fact is true, we
can't infer it from
the simulation.
And to show you that,
statistically valid is not
the same as true,
we'll look at this.
I've introduced a
bug in my simulation.
I've replaced the 4 that
we saw we needed by 2, now,
an easy kind of mistake to make.
And now, if we go to the code--
well, what do you think will
happen if we go to the code
and run it?
We'll try it.
We'll go down here to the code.
We'll make that a 2.
And what you'll see as it
runs is that once again we're
getting very nice confidence
intervals, but totally
bogus values of pi.
So the statistics
can tell us something
about how reproducible
our simulation is
but not whether the
simulation is an actually,
accurate model of reality.
So what do you need to do?
You need to do something
like a sanity check.
So here you might
look at a polygon
and say, well, clearly that's
a totally wrong number.
Something is wrong with my code.
OK, so just to wrap-up.
What we've shown is
a way to find pi.
This is a generally
useful technique.
To estimate the area
of any region r,
you pick an enclosing
region, call
it e, such that it's easy
to estimate the area of e,
and r lies within it.
Pick some random sets of points
within e, let f be the fraction
and fall within r, multiply
e by f and you're done.
So this for example, is a very
common way to do integration.
I promised you we'd
talk about integration.
So here's a sine of x.
If I want to integrate the
sine of x over some region,
as done here, all
I need to do is
pick a bunch of random points,
red and black in this case,
and look at the ratio
of one to the other.
So showing how we
can use randomness
to again, compute something
that is not inherently random.
This is a trick people
use over and over
and over again when confronted
with some situation where
it's not easy to solve
for things mathematically.
You just do a simulation
and if you do it right,
you get a very good answer.
All right, we will move on to
a different topic on Wednesday.